what if our universe comes with a
self-destruct button we to eliminate
itself so cleanly and efficiently that
every single physical thing would just
stop existing and life would be
impossible forever
the ultimate ecological catastrophe
vacuum decay to explain how our universe
could destroy itself we need to
understand two principles one energy
levels a core idea in physics is that
everything has an energy level the
higher the level the more energy is in
the system wood for example has a high
level it can be burned a process that
releases the chemical energy stored in
its molecular bonds and turns it into
heat the ash leftover is at a lower
energy level than the wood before to
stability everything in our universe
tries to move towards its ground state
in which it's completely stable and has
as little energy as possible for example
a ball on the hill is unstable and has a
lot of potential energy when disturbs it
will roll down into the valley and lose
its potential energy in the process the
ball is now in its ground state and
stable it will remain like that
everything in our universe follows these
two principles if something has a lot of
energy its unstable and was to get rid
of it to become stable and reach its
ground state
this is true for every system even in
the weird world of quantum mechanics if
our current understanding of physics is
correct then the universe gets its
properties from quantum fields we
explain them in detail in another video
for this video
imagine them as the rules of the
universe they tell particles how to
behave and interacts like everything in
the universe they want to be in the
lowest energy level possible which is
called a vacuum state this has nothing
to do with vacuum in space it's just
called this way because scientists are
bad at naming things we think all the
fields reached their vacuum state except
maybe one it's possible that the Higgs
field is not stable but metastable which
is a fancy way of saying that it
pretends to be stable but rarely is not
it would be a full vacuum the Higgs
field is responsible for giving
particles their mass which rules how
almost everything in the universe
interacts what would happen if the Higgs
field is in a false vacuum think of our
ball in the valley the ball is the Higgs
field the valley might not be the lowest
energy state for the Higgs field there
might be an even deeper valley that it
wants to get to this would mean that the
Higgs field has a lot of potential
energy waiting to be released the Higgs
field could be like a piece of wood but
drenched in gasoline waiting to set the
universe on fire a random spark like
quantum tunneling could release the
potential energy of the Higgs field this
could happen at any time and without
warning if at any point in space this so
called a vacuum decay starts there is no
turning back as the Higgs field crashes
into the lower energy state it releases
a massive amount of potential energy
this energy pushes the space around it
over the barrier which releases more
potential energy
a sphere of the new stable Hicks field
or true vacuum grows at the speed of
light in all directions imagine it like
setting a sea of gasoline the size of
the universe on fire
the sphere is surrounded by a shun of
energy that devours everything it comes
into contact with whatever it touches is
eliminated from existence the bubble
will continue to grow forever deleting
the universe on its way there is no way
to be warned since it's so fast but
there's nothing we could do anyway
now destruction would be instant in a
fraction of a second earth would be gone
but it actually gets worse if the energy
level of the higgs field changes it
changes all of physics in the true
vacuum of the sphere the standard model
will be overthrown superseded by
different physics that we don't know how
fundamental particles behave how atoms
hold together how chemicals react vacuum
decay won't just destroy life it will
destroy chemistry itself making life as
we know is impossible we simply have no
idea what it would be like in size it
might be a shadow of what it is now or
not we don't know if vacuum decay
happens the outlook is indeed grim if
you feel slightly worried now don't be
at this point false vacuum is
speculation based on our current
understanding of particle physics which
might be wrong
it's kind of like using a ruler to
measure a continent so you can do it but
you might be off by quite a bit at the
end right now
no one can say a vacuum decay is a thing
that's real or just a scary idea but
even if one or multiple spheres of death
have already started expanding the
universe is so big that they might not
reach us for billions of years if
they're far enough away they might not
ever be able to reach us because of the
expansion of the universe the speed of
light is not that fast on the scale of
the universe
so while vacuum decay is fascinatingly
scary right now there are other things
we should be more afraid of
in contrast a vacuum decay we have the
power to prepare for most of them videos
like this one
take hundreds of hours to make so
support us on patreon if you'd like to
learn more about the destruction of
everything it really helps us out we try
to destroy the universe at least once
every few months so let us know in the
comments if you have doomsday scenarios
you would like us to cover